wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
nein dieser wer ist denn das hallo ich
bin nico hallo niko ich bin sebastian
was machst du hier
ich habe ein problem meine tasche ist
weg und mein handy und mein pass sind
auch weg und jahres adresse ist auch weg
okay das ist nicht so gut
und woher kommst du ich komme aus
spanien
ich wohne in sevilla und wer's jahre
jahre alt - tante er hat gesagt sie hat
ja im fahrradladen aber er hat die
adressen nicht auch nicht so gut
und wie alt bist du ich bin 22 jahre alt
und du kommst du aus deutschland ich bin
25 jahre und ja ich komme aus
deutschland
ich komme auch aus deutschland und bin
23 jahre alt kann nico zwei tage hier
wohnen klar kein problem
wir kommen in der wagnergasse dankeschön
es gibt eine party ja aber wir haben ein
kleines problem
wieland ist kaputt kann ich
adam flughafen alles geklappt jetzt
immer gut ja immer als mutter sitzt im
flugzeug und emma geht es gut die flotte
die lampe funktioniert wieder
super micro senken will service trinken
trinken trinken ein getränk oder zwei
oder drei